all right Robert
uh where are you from originally where'd
you grow up uh originally
well I was born in LA
Northridge Hospital and then uh
two years old my dad moved us to San
Diego
and then um
from San Diego
to the time I was uh
I believe 11 12 years old my mom when my
dad and my mom split up
um I moved to uh Hemet San Jacinto Hemet
area it's like kind of by Temecula and
then uh
I got taken out of the house
well
there's a story behind that too as well
but like uh
I got I got taken out of the house
because my mom was
doing drugs and like all that but
um
how would you describe your childhood in
general
uh pretty pretty pretty [__] up but
like no it was pretty [__] up but not
as just like some kids had like way
worse I can you know like what was what
was going on at home that was maybe
you'd call it well I mean she was a
she was high on meth she'd bang her head
against the wall and like make me try
clean my room at 5 30 in the morning
five in the morning and
a lot of verbal abuse a lot of like
physical and stuff like that what was
your dad like my dad uh he was a good
guy but he wasn't really in the picture
um
like um
he would like call like every once once
a month or something like that
um
but um
but every time we did read like
reconnected yeah reconnect it would be
good we could skateboard together and
stuff like that and he was on punk band
in San Diego and uh
how far are you in school oh I I went to
school and
well how far did I go to school like uh
like like you graduated high school no I
didn't I I stopped at like uh 11th grade
yeah I got like 72 credits left or
something like that yeah what uh what
kind of things were you doing
after school oh uh after school when you
were done with school oh um
like when I like stop going to finish
going to school what kind of stuff are
you doing are you working were you yeah
I work like uh construction jobs like
well I lived in Hemet and then my my
grandma took me out of foster care
so um because I was in foster care for
like a couple weeks and my grandma took
me and my sister out
and took us to San Bernardino Mountains
and uh
then my sister went to my other
grandparents and I stayed with my
grandma and always been close to my
grandma since like I was a little kid
and I was like visiting up the mountains
it was like kind of like escape from
like
the bad like you know like I felt more
open to talk to my grandma more than
like
then my mom you know she was kind of
like my second mom you know my dad's mom
and uh
so like uh I'll do like construction
jobs here and there like uh drywall and
stuff and like Landscaping
stuff like that you have an ashtray
right your foot oh right by my foot oh
just on the ground right side all right
here okay but so you
the the problem the trouble you got into
happened when oh oh the pro when I was
getting shot being shot uh this happened
like
in 2020 during like covid time so
recently yeah just recently were you
were you living a lifestyle that kind of
led to that kind of trouble or was it
just yeah I I was like um
I was like really deep in the coke
cocaine and stuff and I was like I was
selling it and stuff
and like
like I uh
I'm not gonna say places but like this
this bar that I'd go to
kind of like a biker bar you know but uh
but right down the street is like a
whole different ball game it's like
that's where I got shot it was like a
place where like that no one knew me
really you know and that was random I
used to go there to eat food and stuff
but like
I never went there during the night and
I did you know
but um
yeah there was like three individuals
and uh
this one guy tried to shake uh my girl's
hand through my face and I was like
I was like back up like what makes you
think that's all right you know I mean
and he was like [__] you tweaker and I
was like I was like tweaker I'm a grown
ass man like last time I checked like
who like like I can do whatever the [__]
I want like who are you and then he's
like well it's up then I'm like what's
up and I knew I was on camera you know
and uh I was like if you want to swing
go ahead Swing Man and then uh
he was getting his fist ready I'm like
like go ahead and swing because like I
was thinking in my head I'll back up
which I did and I backed up and he swung
and I like like you know I leaned back
and then I pushed him
and he slid on the ground and wrapped
around a [__] bar stool and I turned
to my my girl and I get sucker punched
and I turned it to his buddy I pushed
him
and then uh
and then also then uh I pushed him
pretty hard
he fell into some like stool and drinks
and [__] and then this this dude came up
this black dude and like little guy you
know and he came up and pulled put a gun
in my face
this is crazy right here um
I was like do I deserve to get shot over
defending myself like talking to this
guy he has a gun in my face I have my
hands up I'm like hey the bartender and
the owner like come out and they're like
what's going on here what the [__] like
put that [__] away like
we don't need that [__] here you know
and
the guy like puts it back in his waist
and looks at me he's like I'm just
making sure my friends are all right and
like like smiles and Pats his gun while
he's putting in his waist
and then the like the bartender the
owner go back inside the building I'm
still in the back patio
and uh
um
so I right there I was like what am I
gonna do you know these guys are winded
I just pushed them they're looking at me
like they were all African-American or
they were white oh the other two
individuals are I would say they're like
this doesn't really matter what the race
was but yeah their Mexican or they're
Mexican but yeah Mexican or white mixed
or whatever but like
either or I was like it changes in a
[__] up spot like in that [__] up
situation because and then like
when the guy put his gun away he turned
his back and he was talking to a few
people
that's when I I snapped and I started
talking I started talking [__] to him
and uh
like like you know when someone's backs
turn but you can still see their face
I I went off for like a good like 13
minutes 15 minutes of just talking [__]
to this guy because like he just
threatened my life you know and I was in
a situation where like
I was like in fear like I thought like
if I leave right now they're gonna he's
gonna shoot me in the parking lot
because I know he has a gun but I don't
know why but I I ended up pushing the
guy with the gun like I I pushed him
hard into the table he flew and drinks
fell and all that and then he pulled out
the gun and I I froze after I pushed him
I froze I was like oh what the [__] did
I just do you know I mean because like
well I was telling him I was like I want
a fair fight you know I was like like
I'd rather have Arnold Schwarzenegger
pointed a gun at me than like some
weasel you know I mean like I don't know
what it was but
like I was talking [__] like
like you had a cross on his neck I'm
like I bet you don't believe in Jesus
like I bet you don't even know a Bible
verse you know I mean like like uh
I was like I was talking [__] and I
could tell he was getting angry and then
like just when I pushed him though
it was like uh
I froze and then like I remember he was
on the table
and he's pulling it out and then he gets
back on his feet off the table and it
was like kind of like I don't know if
this is going to kill you but [__] you
and he shot three times one of them uh
flew by my head
and one of them hit me but I went like
sideways like this because I didn't want
to be like a Target like this I went
like this and it caught me right here my
bullet's still in me right here
it was a pretty big slug yeah it's
pretty big I don't think it was a 40 or
a 45 I don't know what it was a pretty
big gun and then uh I got one in the leg
and like my first I dropped and uh the
first one I was like ah what the like
like your adrenaline pops off and you're
like
but like I dropped on the ground
and like my first like response was like
run that way it'll run down this way
or jump over this wall but he started
running and I ended up chasing him like
I don't know why I got up and I started
chasing him were there drugs in your
system that made you uh yeah yeah yeah
there was yeah I'm gonna be honest yeah
there's cocaine and uh like uh meth I
mean and [__] I was like if you're clean
you probably wouldn't behave differently
yeah yeah definitely and uh and I'm not
like
yeah it's sort of like
yeah I definitely would have behaved
differently or if I had a friend that
was like Hey this ain't a good idea man
this guy has a gun while you're talking
[__] let's get the hell out of here but
half of me was afraid because like the
the owner in the bartender went back in
the building
they're not escorting the guy with the
gun out they're not like like I'm alone
and my girlfriend was fed up with my
[__] she walked away at the time because
she didn't want nothing to do with the
situation
but later on she did save my life though
but like um
so he starts running and I chase him and
I was like like in the movies I was
going like left and right
and he was like because at the door at
the door they were stopping him like
everybody was running because when the
gunshots are shot everybody's
fleeing you know and like the door was
clogged up and he was trying to get out
and I was gonna I was like I'm gonna get
that gun and shove it up his ass you
know like I want to get that gun and
I don't know what I was thinking like so
I ran after him
and he was like oh okay and then like he
he was surprised you know and like okay
you want some more all right and then
like she was going like this and I was
like oh you're gonna go that way I'm
gonna go this way you know and I got the
one in the neck I I'm not sure if I got
two in the neck
but there's like this one was like right
between the two windpipes and then I got
one in the mouth and I'm like oh I
[__] up you know like this is pretty
bad but I was like I'm gonna get closer
and I started getting closer
and uh he's trying to climb over this
wall because like you know when you let
off shots like someone that's doing a
crime you gotta go you gotta leave
because the window of opportunity to you
know
I don't whatever but like he was jumping
on the he was on the wall
and he got me in the forehead and that's
when I was like that one I felt a lot
this one and this one I didn't like I
think my adrenaline was so up and crazy
but the one in the forehead it was like
wow it was like a computer like
shutting down it felt like and uh
I was like oh I felt like a baseball bat
and I was like oh and then like
and then he pops me in the eye of the
eyebrow
it was like a half circle right here I
could still feel it like uh
I'm sure if it went in my eye socket and
blew out it would have been done you
know but like it got me right here which
is still like the hard skull
I thought half of my face was gone and
that's how you lost your eye yeah that's
how I lost my eye and I was like I
thought half my face was gone I'm like
damn I'm gonna die and I'm like
all right dude I don't want to play no
more because he's on the wall and then
there's like a doorway where he was
trying to leave
but now he's trying to jump over the
wall but I'm still chasing him
pops me in the eye I run inside the
building
he he chases me
and he's still trying to get head shot
on my on me
there's like bullets like it's a weird
sound it's like a
like a spinning like Zippity sound like
but he's shooting me inside the building
I'm staggering because like I have one
eye now and it's dark in there
and I'm hearing like glass breaking
behind me and wood breaking like he's
trying to get me
and uh
I remember stumbling
um my girlfriend told me that he was
like pistol whipping me like I remember
like it was like lightning like like I
was thinking this could have been from
the bullet in my head but like after I
look at my head a few times there's a
lot of dinks and dents and like he was
hitting me good like I think he unloaded
the clip and then like you know it's
starting to hit me and my uh girlfriend
jumped on him
and uh he was a little little guy and
she's she's not a big girl like she's
not fat or anything she's like fit but
she's a little taller than him and she
jumped on him and said why are you doing
this stop doing this
like leave him alone you're hurting him
or something like or something like that
and uh
I guess he dropped his uh he dropped his
gun and his cell phone and he grabbed
his gun and he ran but he left his cell
phone and that's how he got caught but
um so he did get caught yeah he did get
caught where is he today uh he's in
prison now for a long time yeah
but um
I know you like uh
but yeah and it's like
this Mexican guy picked me up
and like me and him weren't really that
cool at all I remember in the beginning
of the night he was kind of like the guy
was giving me attitude and stuff but he
picked he felt bad and he picked me up
and we started running towards the
kitchen and I was thinking in my head
like I just took all these shots and I'm
running with this guy I think I'm gonna
make it but I didn't I had no idea like
like uh I thought that it hit me on the
top of the head like like you know
grazed but I didn't know it was right in
the forehead did you have a scar on your
forehead yeah I got a scar right here
this is where the bullet entered
any what do you have on top of your head
I have a I have three plates right here
and eight screws like they did a really
good job like I don't know like uh
but I ran into the kitchen with this
Mexican guy
and I remember like
laying there in the hallway and uh
uh I remember they yelled someone yelled
out the shooter's still in the building
like he's still in the building the
shooter and I thought he's gonna come
back and be like hey dude remember me
[__] and like try you know
finish me
but um
that didn't happen and I guess you
eventually was out of the building I
remember the cops came in
and there's Mexican guys telling me like
one two three just kept saying one two
three to say it out loud
but
um the cops came in they walked over me
with their guns and stuff because they
got like
secure the perimeter make sure like
everyone's safe before EMS comes to help
me because uh they're like talking about
a football game and [__] like I don't
know like when they I don't know they're
talking about something but I was like
where's EMS you know but like I didn't
realize they have to secure the
perimeter and all that
and uh
I'm sorry I'm a little nervous and [__]
but uh no but um
I remember talking the Mexican guy I
don't know his name but I think he
showed up to court it's like because I
think he was a cook or something I'm not
sure but you're like
he showed up to like Court to testify
against the guy
I don't I still don't know his name I
should figure that one out but like
I I was like it was like in the movies
like am I gonna die and he's like you're
not gonna die and I'm like you know how
you know like a grown man is lying to
you like like all right I'm gonna die
huh I guess I'll just relax you know and
I almost like passed out you know but
he's like he's like no I don't know if
you slap him to slap me but he's like I
know he's shaking he's like one two
three say one two three and I started
yelling one two three
and I remember my girlfriend was like
real hysterical
but I didn't want to be like
like babe I I couldn't look at her you
know I just kept saying one two three
one two three I'm gonna live you know
but I didn't know I had a hole in my
forehead you know like like
of course like anybody around is gonna
be like this guy's gonna die you know
you're like he got hit like so many
times
but the the ambulance finally show up
and they're um
they're they're taking their their sweet
time you know and I I was like can you
guys hurry up a bit you know because I
think they're getting ready to call the
coroner like not like they're like you
know they seem like they're putting the
gurney away kind of [__] I'm like hey do
I have to is this gonna be a lawsuit oh
my God then all of a sudden they speed
it up and like got me on the gurney
foreign
and uh
I remember uh getting on the I remember
the whole thing until I got to the
hospital but like I got on the gurney
and uh
I actually thought my girlfriend was
following us the whole time it was
actually a cop
like uh following the because they
thought it was like Gang Related or
something like that they thought it was
something like we I don't know what they
thought really but like
I'm sure like any kind of shooting
thing would uh happened they didn't
think anything but um
but um I kept saying one two three in
the in the ambulance and they're like
what the [__] are you saying dude why
are you saying that over and over and uh
I think that probably kept me I don't
know if it kept oxygen in me saying that
over and over but
I was thinking in my head like
if I'm um on my way like in the movies
like like usually it's like on the way
to the hospital you usually die or right
when you get there you know and like
I'm like all right I'm almost to the
hospital I'm PR I'm gonna live I'm gonna
make it you know
and then when I when I got to the
hospital
all these nurses and doctors were like
staring at me and they weren't even
saying anything it was quiet and I'm
like I was like don't let me die like I
was in the wrong place at the wrong time
I'm not a piece of [__] like I have a
son and like
I'm like please don't let me die like
and they're just like staring at me but
I'm thinking now that I didn't know that
I actually had a hole in my forehead so
they probably never seen that in a long
time like working there but I mean I'm
sure they've seen a lot of crap did they
remove the bullet from your forehead no
they left it they left the bullet in my
brain and what about the one in your eye
uh the one in my eye blew up and uh
the one in my mouth actually broke six
of my teeth took out six of my teeth
and bounce up in the roof of my uh mouth
into my sinus cavity there was a hole in
my science cavity for a minute
that's a whole different story because
like they ended up finding out about
that later on and they got me into
surgery again because I was like
enjoying applesauce and [__] I'm like I
was like enjoying I was like where's the
mashed potatoes and cheese I want
something like and they're like hey wait
a minute like this guy has a hole in the
roof of his mouth because they took a
piece of my cheek and plugged up the
hole because they don't want um
this is before the surgery they're like
we need to get them in the surgery now
and I'm like can you guys not put me in
on a tube again you know because I was
just just enjoying food again
but not sure enough I woke up and I had
a tube in my nose and they're feeding me
through my nose with like the fluid and
stuff but I kept thinking like I'll
sacrifice this discomfort so my mouth
can heal
because like
there's a lot of things I don't want to
tell you in the hospital to stress you
out and stuff like that which is
understandable
so they got me into surgery and I woke
up and I had like I was getting fed with
the tube
and uh
but uh what was I gonna say I forgot
um
so you've you've fully recovered now
yeah yeah
um
yeah surprisingly I've fully for like
what was it uh but yeah they left this
bullet in I still got to get that
checked out
I don't know what about what the one on
the neck that they left out in or they
took it out
but this one inside blew up in my face
the one in my eye like it it hit my
eyebrow and I took out my eye I don't
know I don't think it didn't go like
yeah it just took out my eye
but the one in my brain the the
neurologic surgeon
showed me pictures and uh
uh it broke through my skull and a
little I don't know if the bullet blew
up on my because the front of your skull
is pretty hard it's like the hardest
part of the skull and like a little
piece flew inside
and it stopped right in between the two
pieces of meat like on the pictures it
was just like either to the right to the
left you know I mean like vegetable or
whatever they're really surprised you
know are there any Mental effects from
from this yeah it was like like I get a
lot of emotional effects like I get um
you get a lot of anxiety and stuff like
I have a I had a ton of PTSD
from it
like a
kept getting nightmares a lot like uh
like a dream I was in like a grocery
store
and it was like they got the same guy
like
like the shooters in the building kind
of thing and then like I see the guy in
the aisle in the dream I still kind of
remember it
and I'm like not this again you know I
mean like in my dream I'm like I'm out
like you know I'm not doing this [__]
again but like that that sucked and then
like also I thought like
like when I woke up in the hospital it
was like on a Thursday I went in and
then I woke up on a Sunday so it was
like 30 40 hours of like surgery on me
and I woke up and uh
there's this uh there's this black dude
in a mask because it was during covid I
thought he was one of the family members
of the shooter I got scared I'm like I
didn't know what was going on but it was
actually like a D.A or like a not a D.A
like a
homicide detective that's what he was he
was a homicide detective
and he was just talking to me and stuff
but like
but uh
yeah and then uh my friend Brad he lied
my sister was there and he lied and said
he was my brother he actually has one
eye but he was born like that and he was
kind of the last person I wanted to see
once I figured out I lost my it wasn't
like anything personal it was like come
on Brad I don't know you know like I
just woke up and I was like he's like
now we have we're a pair now and I'm
like over a pair like I mean I mean you
lost your eye when you were born but I
lost you know I mean but like he was
just trying to be there to be like for
comfort
what have you learned from all of this I
learned like uh
basically like uh
like your pride will get you killed like
you know I mean your mouth can you gotta
watch your mouth and uh
also when you're in like an environment
or territory or not like if you're in
that area and you don't do your homework
on it you know I mean you're gonna
you get results you know like that you
know I mean and like I was alone and
because I told him I was like let's have
a fair one let's have a fight blah blah
but it's not like I was like I don't
have no weapons on me but he doesn't
know that at all you know I mean like
but like I don't know down there like
like holding a gun is like holding a
cell phone for some people but the drugs
that gave you the uh
yeah the Courage the courage to Smart
office I think it's like
the the ignorance inside the brain like
well I'm gonna show them that I'm not
like
some soft white boy that's like
like I'm I'm like you could be that like
I don't know you're not gonna you're not
the badass you know I mean like it ain't
like it ain't like that you know but um
how has your life changed from after
this well um I'm like um
you're still using
um um here and there like I relapsed I
was like a whole
to be honest like a whole year clean and
sober and then like
um
got a warehouse job and then they let me
go and then like well they they it was
just for like the Thanksgiving Rush kind
of thing I thought it was going to be
like a long time
but um it was just like a temp agency
and uh
just recently yeah like a whole year I
was just smoking weed and that's it no
no alcohol no drugs
but uh did a little bit of cocaine on
New Year's Eve and drank uh
kind of felt stupid and then like
but I realized like I could always go
back I have like a lot of control in my
mind but um
do you blame the drugs for why this all
happened
oh me getting shot um
at first I was blaming like I was
blaming everything but me at first and
then I realized it was like no I gotta
like take like
like I got um what is it like take
responsibility set your responsibility
for what like
for what it was and it was basically
like
that like you gotta learn how to walk
away but you know like
I thought in my head I can I can go over
San Bernardino Inland Empire anywhere I
want like no one's gonna mess with me
but it ain't like that like you know
like
like someone like
I don't know at the end of the day like
yeah I don't know but yeah it's kind of
crazy
do you have kids
yeah I have a uh I have a nine-year-old
are you in his life no I'm not like uh
I'm I'm working on that right now
I have to get like uh
well she took off on me when I was like
when she when he was three
and then like
I was sober like the whole time like
right when he was born like I was like
holding him I'm like I got like I was
drunk one night and I was holding him
and I was like I gotta stop alcohol and
[__] this is like I felt like a piece of
[__] like If I Stumble like one
time or something heard him like
yeah like so I quit alcohol and
I wasn't doing hard drugs at the time or
anything but like for three years and
then like right when she took them away
like
I went right like into like that mode
again like I mean like
well before I mean I don't know I
dabbled here and there but like
but I can't use that excuse either you
know I mean I gotta own up to that [__]
too like you're like what would you say
is the most important lesson you've
learned from all of this
um from being shot or like or just
you're just in life in general not just
life in general like uh be grateful like
you know like
and that that your life can get snatched
you know like I could have lost my other
eye could have died I could have died
um
like I've had a few friends that
well I had one friend that got shot he
got shot by one bullet and died you know
and it was over an argument like who's
the biggest and toughest
but the gun will take care of that
conversation real quick you know I mean
and uh
like I I never really like
like it sucks that sometimes like it
takes situations like that
so realize what it what it's about you
know I mean like yeah like I could have
got my life taken from me
but also when I when I was in the
hospital I was crying about my eye like
I lost my eye not my [__] eye this
nurse was like you're walking you're
talking you're going to the you're going
to the bathroom and back
um this girl got shot in the back by her
boyfriend and she's paralyzed now she's
19. her parents parents take care of her
and uh
and I was like
I gotta take that blessing for her
because like you know I'm a lot older
than her
she's 19.
I was just like I gotta take that
blessing and be grateful you know I mean
you get depressed now huh you get
depressed over this oh yeah all the time
yeah definitely it's a different kind of
depression like like I used to get
depressed once in a while but it's like
it's a lot different
what are you playing and doing now
um right now
um
well I was trying I was trying to get
disability and they denied me over and
over and over and over so I got a lawyer
and like and I got the judge we had like
a court thing on the phone and like
the judge was like uh
like good luck to you Robert I grant you
da da you know and
they're trying to prove like
if I was able to work with one eye like
they're talking about some football
player that could throw the football
pretty good with one eye and all that
and I was trying to tell him like I got
a bullet in my brain and when I bend
down to pick stuff up it's like a lot of
pressure in my head and like um
but they're like they granted it to me
and then like two or three weeks later I
get a thing in the mail it was a real
big disappointment uh denied but I was
just trying to like I wasn't trying to
milk the system or anything I was just
trying to get some help you know I was a
thing I could do side work on the side
to like like you know get something
going
like I'm working on getting a prosthetic
eye and uh because I'm tired of people
like staring at me and stuff and if it's
like
like in the warehouse job everybody's
like staring at me after a while it's
just like whatever like you know I I
didn't explain my story to anybody or
anything like that
but like
I do I can relate on people getting shot
though like you know like I realize it
you know
I could definitely relate like
what they've been through and how it is
like I'm thankful that I have like
family that were there for me and like
because it could have been a whole
different situation you know
but I went I went in there in like
October 17th oh no wait it was September
17th and I got out October 6th so it was
pretty good it was fast recovery I
almost escaped the hospital too and
stuff like that I was like jumping over
the fence and they put a shot in my ass
and [__] because I wanted to leave I was
like I hate I hate hospitals you know
like
I had a concussion in eighth grade and I
got airlifted to ICU other than the
children's area hearing kids screaming
and stuff when I woke up but like
I don't know like uh
I was really like disrespectful to a lot
of the nurses and doctors my uncle told
me you got to go back there and like and
thank them for helping you and being
there for you and
he's right and the one nurse I wasn't
like it's a small world too you know I
mean like the one nurse I was nice to
was my friend's mom you know from from
where I'm from I was just like you know
but
but also being shot in the frontal lobe
like I don't know there's a lot of
things
all right Robert thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah yeah thank you I
wish you lots of luck from here